for those of you who recommended this
series to me [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you for doing this or making sure i
don't want to read anything else
i can't put down the [ __ ] series
[Music]
first two books in the series you can
check out my reviews
great i mean seriously great holy [ __ ]
great like i
loved those books the third book
everyone says it's the best
and i'm starting to think they may be
right basically the book is split into
two halves in the first half we're
following roland suzanna and eddie
susana and eddie we met in the drawing
of the three and now we get to kind of
see them interact
more jake and roland are psychologically
connected
through events that i won't spoil in the
gunslinger basically they need to
bring jake into their world so
once again i'm gonna do first half
spoiler free second half
spoilers so first half it's great read
it
dark tower the wastelands is it one of
the best
i don't know it's either the drawing of
the three
they're all so different that's the
problem i can't really pick a favorite
at the moment once again stephen king
gives us the action
that we love what's interesting is that
like on every
cover of this book is blame the mono
his depiction on book covers is nothing
like he is
described in the in the book but
basically blaine
the train is foreshadowed throughout the
whole book but he's
he just appears at the very end
essentially if if i had any other
complaints is that maybe the writing
felt at times a little rushed especially
in the first half of the book the
writing didn't feel as
inspired or whatever you want to call it
didn't feel i didn't feel that stephen
king
urgency a lot of jake strolling around
new york city streets in 1977 which
is cool but it gets a little repetitive
anyways now's a good time as ever to get
into spoilers so if you haven't read the
book you want to get into the dark tower
series just do it like you don't need to
watch this review just just do it i want
to talk a little bit about that
scene in the mansion the mansion that
jake enters
is is quite scary and in a great uh
cool scene it reminded me of monster
house
so um there's that but when
jake actually finally gets to
mid world and embraces roland my eyes
may have watered
a little bit jake is very forgiving of
the guy who basically let him die
um it's pretty funny actually kids you
know
it felt it really felt like stephen king
somehow gave this
weight and and really made it feel like
once jake was there
and when oi joined oh oy the bumbler
which is is like the best character in
the whole book
when they're all together finally it
really they really feels complete
you know their quartet feels whole
and it's such a warm feeling getting to
sit around the fire hear them exchange
riddles and and tell stories and joke at
each other
and they just have such a lovely like
weird family dynamic
once that dynamic is so firmly
established then it's all threatened
when they get into the city of blood
what's his name the gasher or whatever
his name the
that horrible guy couldn't stand him the
guy who kidnaps jake
but i was way more concerned about oy
the whole time i don't know about you
guys but
when there's like a dog in a book or a
movie and
stephen king is so unpredictable i'm
just like if you if you
kill i know oy isn't a dog he's a
bumbler but you know basically just like
a a weird dog
i just kept thinking okay if jake dies
like you know
it happens but stephen king if you do
anything to oy the bumbler like i will
never forgive you
that that is unforgivable oy gets
injured but thankfully he doesn't
die jesus you know that scene where
where roland is like
having oi go spy for him while jake is
is taken hostage roland is thinking like
i think king ends the section or the
chapter or whatever by saying
and roland knew that he would likely
never see oy again
i'm like dude have you not learned your
lesson
like the first time with letting jake
die in the gunslinger like oy
is part of the team roland is
problematic
jake you know makes it out you know
eddie and susanna
are dealing with playing the mono and
talk about
like a villain being set up perfectly
for the love of god
show me the train i never thought i'd be
doing that in a book i never thought i'd
be going
show me the goddamn train caring about a
train was the most interesting thing in
this book of course when we see him
it's like he's a pink train the shape of
the train is very sleek futuristic and
he's described like a humpback whale
the only thing i wish that would maybe
like complete the book a little better
is if
king had put the ending i was lo i'm
lucky you know because i'm reading all
this after the fact so as
soon as i finished the wastelands i just
picked up wizard and glass and just
read the ending you know i don't know i
think there are good things about the
cliffhanger but
overall it's a bit of an annoyance
here's my theory because wizard and
glass is basically a long
long flashback i think that king maybe
knew that it wouldn't be as popular
because it's not really advancing the
dark tower story and he didn't want
people or his publisher
to try to sell it as like a prequel so
he's like you know what i'm going to
put a huge cliffhanger on the wastelands
so that when wizarding glass comes out
and it's just a flashback people are
going to have to read the book because
they need to know about the ending
of the wastelands if that's the case
which i suspect it is
that's pretty brilliant because i hate
prequels i'm very happy that i am
reading
wizard and glass which is basically an
extended flashback and
you basically you have to read it you
got to see what happens to blame the
mono right
moral of the story this series continues
to be fantastic i will probably be done
in with wizarding glass in about a week
and then i'll have a review up for that
the wastelands may be the most
satisfying of the three books because
the group is together
books one and two are kind of like
setting up the dynamic
and now we have our qat now we are going
towards the dark tower
[ __ ] is getting real king just has a way
of of creating such
great and fun and interesting group
dynamics
you really feel like these are real
people interacting with one another
that's what i have to say thank you for
watching like and subscribe
like and subscribe smash that like
button have a good one everyone